[Music]
Osaka Japan a rambunctious merchant town
with a huge heart
follow to see no cigar go yogi SOS tera
Mastana 2.0 este mapa gah no toyou a
delta bacio
in a country known for politeness and
diffidence this city is forging its own
path people in this town are some
friendly super you're ever going to be
in Japan but it's in the kitchen where
Osaka really makes its mark
the food is better the people are
friendlier the night life goes on longer
three prouder seconds are taking you on
a unique tour of their city showing you
the hidden spots they think everyone
should see if only they knew where to
look
now Maya
haitatsu shochu our video was a
chihuahua eat am i by any standards
caisson is an early riser he's a regular
visitor to a sucker's daily fish market
which gets going into an eye-watering
4:00 a.m. yeah I look Lloyd a John was
it a job
yeah hey Lamar
sorry II Germany Ecuador yeah buddy
my work are mo - MO I didn't mail it in
solution
hundreds of species of fish are sold
here but it's the tuna auction that's
the real star of the show and loud
frantic race against time
we're whole fish are sold to the highest
bidder and stalemates are decided in a
game of rock-paper-scissors
[Music]
major fish markets in Japan and the
visitors even if you're not buying it's
the unique atmosphere that draws people
here
[Music]
you guys gonna yeah taro Jared Oh golly
that's what you lose at eight times the
size of our suckers baseball stadium
it's easy for visitors to lose
themselves in a labyrinth of side alleys
and stalls no saga no sugu Benghazi saga
niveau robbery
nah nobody Hara Hachi Hachi
[Music]
elsewhere other residents prefer to
start the day in a slightly more
leisurely fashion this is hose ng it's
one of the first couples that I visited
in Osaka a lot of times I'll just come
here early in the morning
originally from America artist hoary
Benny has been living in Osaka for
thirteen years and he's still
discovering hidden pockets of the city
seemingly forgotten by the 21st century
there's a lot of places around Osaka
that are inspiring the whole city's
inspires sometimes you need to have
those little moments where you can get
away from all that where you can go to a
place it's a little more quiet and it's
nice when you come to a place like this
and you see all of these kind of loud
rambunctious rancorous residents in this
city and then you know they're coming
here and they're taking a few minutes
out of their data smell the roses if you
will after much of the city was leveled
in the Second World War
older buildings are less common here
than you might think but Benny always
brings friends to the hidden temples
that have stood the test of time
a bit of the old Japan
everyone sort of pictures Japan is neon
jungle which is very true but you know
Sokka it's a lot easier to really get
up-close and experience it on a real
personal level
[Music]
Bennie's art means that he tends to get
very personal indeed with his clients
[Music]
when I first came here I had no
intention of tattooing at all I didn't
even have any tattoos and it really got
its hooks in me
tattoos aren't as socially accepted in
Japan as they are in West but Ben has
still managed to carve out an impressive
niche for himself in a culture that
values professionalism highly
there's no such thing as a menial job in
Japan people who clean the train
platform are just as important as the
people who drive the trains and that is
a very sobering lesson in humility I
think for all of us in a country where
Western influences are widespread
you'll soon appreciate that Japanese
culture permeates every experience
cadets qorikancha seminary 3d
atera see Osaka Hey Mukul
[Music]
more suger anomic Cara haruga could
watashi wa wa dekinai Otis Otis nocebo
tava she's Indus also Connie crush the
drokken ending myself
[Music]
this is missionary ward while a lot of
visitors wouldn't think to come to this
less affluent area kamiya-san believes
it has far more to offer than the
well-worn tourist trails
ohayo gozaimsau even something is every
day is a trip to get new business cards
and offer an opportunity to see
centuries-old crafts Oklahoma caution
will come in and oh damn Okinawa canting
I want to know much much hi arigatou
gozaimasu come here son
no it's gonna mess you up yeah total
specialities not does another Congress
on mojoh aira
this modular you will not not have it
there to my to my co colored out Scott
it's good to critique Iraq this
it isn't your average holiday memento
but it's a great conversation starter
for business travelers stone eco divino
Pato Chopin Cerrito kini stana gift o
dot Omo Omo Luna musica para mother who
presented a unique kangaroo bar I cannot
imam or three teen i must earn it
mimi no shiro de l'année having taken a
break early from his business for the
day Ben is in need of Senhora da
japanese-style
and his favorite place to go is his
local center
if you come you should definitely try to
go to a settle it's not something for
the bashful I've seen people come from
abroad sometimes and they want to insist
that maybe wearing some swimming trunks
or something into the into the bath
don't do that nobody's going to be
staring too much a center is a public
bathhouse a cultural experience with its
own unique dress code but naked or not
as with all aspects of Japanese life
there are still customs to respect when
you walk in you're not supposed to just
jump in the bath right away if there's
like these little stalls where you sit
in front of those and you kind of lather
up and you know wash your face wash your
body after washing make sure there's no
soap left on your body before hopping
into the bath
and of course everyone has their own
more personal rituals communal bath
houses have been a feature of Japanese
society for hundreds of years but it was
only after the Second World War that
sent us became an integral part of
Japanese urban life
there was a compulsive War
Reconstruction era where people didn't
have a lot of running water or gas in
their homes and so people in local
communities would gather in bath houses
and that sort of really cemented them I
guess as part of Japanese culture male
men women kids you know old people young
people everybody it's kind of wild
families come together to prevent too
many blushes there are separate sections
for men and women I guess when you go to
sento there is a sort of as a sense of
community to see the same people and you
know everybody's working different jobs
but you know what's to come inside y'all
sort of take it together in the same
soup bowl if you will ben is a big fan
but he's not welcome in all centers as
tattoos are still associated with
organized crime just be aware that a lot
of them don't allow you to come in if
you've got tattoos so if you're not sure
either get a Japanese friend to help you
or ask them when you come in really when
you're done with your day and like all
your muscles are tense this is just a
place where you can go in completely and
totally you know relax and but what's
going to bother you
[Music]
well sumo or baseball might spring to
mind when you think of Japanese
competition the board game go is in a
different league and it's in game salons
like this where Chi San likes to relax
you are your belly at all always you
know this that's an end it what else
should I step out more an animal common
residence you don't know what doesn't it
go is a strategy game where the aim is
to claim more of the board than your
opponent it's simple to learn but
deceptively hard to master
you walk while I generally choose okay
most people play this game so be bold
and ask them to explain the basics but
it has to be our saga for the antennas
you gotta say you don't know sort of
beautiful gender should an extra dozen
very bad so they're hydrogen
this ancient game is taken very
seriously
fortunately there's a ranking system so
for newcomers of-the-art is choosing a
suitable opponent and with 14 million
players worldwide chances are you won't
be short of a partner
but if board games aren't your cup of
green tea the street food might offer a
bit more adventure for Kanaya Sam there
are certain specialities that all
visitors have to try the quark you are
also causing nausea shock Lukas takoyaki
is an octopus filled batter board
fast-food a soccer style examine it
well I am NOT a quirky no as it another
kid or whatever ahi it also Kazuya
Cocozza night aqua regular miss osaka is
widely regarded as the food capital of
Japan for kamiya-san the best in fast
food can be found here on the streets of
shin sekai some whether to give you a
taste of the real a sucker
ha ha ha no xote I keep to a Korean
wattage is no such as you thought they
were solo who go there and for dessert
you can always treat the kids to a
lollipop or to positiveness on a stick
fresh from the fish market while Kanaya
san enjoys an early dinner a couple of
regulars have already dropped by to Kai
sands restaurant kernels as a nanny
we patent a few money donors user this
is a capo restaurant an intimate place
where customers sit together on the same
level as the chef a dining style
invented in Osaka by using uh Manny ho
niki de Beauford omission e ro Mahadev
ester ah yeah pari madam
Tabata photo Nanaimo no tablet I started
a seconds are eager to share the tastes
of their hometown and small restaurants
like chi sounds can be found all over
the city which in the end of my eye
Serrano a kimono a futari given a Godot
sorry Showa to the wall Tata Guinea
quick hands in a agador Kochi Danuta
Ganga coated and guises and knee but
there are also good deeds happiness at a
time
Ostara euro Gandhi more I'll just a
whole day you will dijimos I get on it
at all more take the non Daegu decided
peponi wanna linger
kun you as you got demo starts no Chico
get in it I know there's no menu diners
gets a selection of intricately prepared
dishes of the day but equally important
is making friends over a plate of food
well no touchy no sake of war
yo Gonzalez era much torn at some point
on mr. ma Hogan Oh Toyo Adagio
[Music]
on the other side of town Ben is off to
enjoy a sucker's famous nightlife
in Japan you're walking on the streets
these buildings full of sides and you
like can I go in that place there seems
to be bars in that place even if the
entrance looks a little bit intimidating
you should at least try to put your hand
on the door handle it and open it up and
see what's inside
fun playing on the edge of the bustling
America Mura district is one of Benny's
favorite bars
[Music]
you'll see this kind of a flourishing
nightlife a lot of people have set up
their own little bars a lot of them are
very personality driven and in Osaka bar
Amina's have no shortage of imagination
for a lot of these people they tried to
put their own personal touch on it
there's several bars around Osaka
there's a Buddhist themed bar which is
all about people who are into Buddhist
statues there's like a railroad themed
bar people who are into trains hi I own
the Honda's ah and whatever you discover
you can be sure of a warm welcome
I would suggest people come to Osaka
rather than Tokyo because the food is
better the people are friendlier the
nightlife goes on longer you don't have
to spend years and years trying to prove
yourself to these people usually after
one or two nights they're gonna see you
as a fellow of Sutton
Osaka is a city that rewards those who
died right in and whatever you do leave
your inhibitions at the door everyone
else has
you
you